qué bonita noche gracias por estar acá
voy a empezar con dos historias por las
cuales estoy aquí la primera fue cuando
tenía siete años aproximadamente yo
estaba obsesionado con un refresco en
polvo de fresa no se puede decir la
marca y ya está me lo tenían prohibido
en mi casa el caso es que una vez no
estaban mis papás nos dejaron solo a mis
hermanos y yo con mis ahorros se me fue
la tienda más cercana compré tres cajas
un kilo de azúcar y saqué mi bote de la
ropa sucia que era como este tamaño al
patio lo llené de agua leche todo el
refresco en polvo un kilo de azúcar y me
dice mi refresco gigante me metí con mis
monitos adentro y me tomé en medio medio
bote y ese día cumplí mi primer sueño de
mi vida
locura si oye raro pero esta fue una
experiencia de verdad inolvidable la
segunda fue cuando tenía más o menos 17
años un sábado el viernes previo yo
jugabas que tuve un juego en el que me
fue muy muy bien y el sábado siguiente
me despierto y ya después de desayunar
yo al cuarto y pues yo creo que me
sentía muy bien o muy motivado y de la
nada se me viene a la mente la frase
venimos a pasarla bien y en ese momento
me impactó y me emocioné ellos solo me
empecé a dar las cuerdas y decidí otra
vez con mis ahorros este ir a una
oficina todavía no había dominios por
internet y una oficina y compré el
dominio por varios años y dije nombre
con esto voy a hacer algo bien rápido y
me voy a tener que estudiar y pulse vean
de aquí
yo actualmente
estoy muy consciente con esas cosas de
cómo es nuestro origen cuando nacemos
como venimos de un acto de amor es
cuando más reales y somos más quién
realmente somos entre más cercanos
estamos a nuestra fecha de concepción no
nos han pasado cosas malas en la vida no
hemos tenido tantas amistades y otras
cosas entonces realmente somos más puros
por eso es bien importante hacerle caso
al origen ahorita vamos a ir
desarrollando como cómo vamos a explicar
estos estos términos la creatividad yo
actualmente me dedico a la creatividad
de profesión pero la creatividad tiene
un problema que la relación a mucha
gente con un tema artístico o de
vocación o de inspiración etcétera yo
con todos los años que tengo en esto
tengo una definición de creatividad que
es mi favorita creatividad es crear
donde no hay recursos eso ha sido la más
práctica y es la que a mí se me hace más
amigable les invito por qué a que les
guste yo además de mi profesión con la
creatividad logré encontrar la felicidad
lo voy a practicar porque
mi papá falleció hace un año de un
cáncer muy fuerte fue una enfermedad que
duró dos años muy muy desgastante la
verdad me pasó que personalmente se me
fueron mis ahorros o sea tuve que entrar
a las enfermedades son super caras tuve
que entrarle con todo tenía no sé diez
años trabajando y pues se me fue todo
emocionalmente pues se me estaba yendo
mi mi mi papá y me causaba bastante
conflicto entras a roles familiares
muchas cosas que era una época muy
difícil yo siempre he sido una persona
relativamente optimista pero en estos
momentos han dado en un hoyo se fue la
época como más triste de mi vida como la
mitad del periodo enfermedad mío para un
día trabajando me llegó un correo y el
correo era la renovación del dominio de
venimos a pasarla bien y me llegó la
frase yo ni siquiera me acordaba de ella
y me sembró de que dije órale
o sea el cnr de 17 años me está mandando
un correo digo así lo que es interpretar
yo no me gusta la fantasía me está
mandando un correo y me está recordando
quién
soy yo realmente y me impactó mucho
mucho la idea
el caso es que ahí practique la
felicidad porque lo que no había en ese
momento de mi vida era felicidad
realmente estaba en un panorama muy duro
y triste y en base a la creatividad y a
esa persona yo mismo de los 17 años
logré encontrar felicidad donde no había
por un recuerdo que tuve entonces fue
algo súper súper interesante con el cual
para no quedar mal como que de los 17
años que iba a hacer algo y no lo hice
hasta 18 años después de 18 años paganos
de dominio en cuenta me había dado como
que lo pague por mucho tiempo
entonces dije por las ideas
y no las haces es como si no existieran
entonces como en ese momento sentí
felicidad con eso como que fue un escape
mío o un proceso psicológico de
protección empezar a dedicarle mucho
tiempo venimos a pasarla bien decidí
imprimir unas calcomanías subí a mi
instagram que tenía unas calc así que
era un recuerdo de cuando estaba joven
bueno
más o menos este y explicaba que es una
perspectiva frente a la vida que la vida
es un homenaje que hay que disfrutarla y
me eche un rollo bastante agradable y
para mi sorpresa ese día fueron la
oficina como 150 personas de las cuales
yo conocía a 2030 y no soy influencia ni
nada de eso no o sea no tengo tantos
seguidores y durante la semana andaba
como cholo con mi cartera y mis
calcomanías en la otra bolsa y adonde
iba estaba repartiendo calcar o
inconscientemente si funcionaba mi
cerebro y empezó a regalar calcas y
calcas y queda que es el momento en el
que yo no tenía felicidad pero la
anhelaba entonces fue mi comportamiento
natural o sea nuestros creadores es es
muy bien si no sabes estamos diseñados
perfectamente para poder hacer esas
cosas el caso es que después de estar
practicando con esta con esta regalada
de stickers y regalando felicidad y todo
esto que era lo que menos tenía me
empecé a dar cuenta que el hecho de
regalar
significa algo súper importante y si no
me puse a profundizar un poco más
este cuando re se regala algo
normalmente pues cuando es tu cumpleaños
cuando cumpliste algún objetivo cuando
hay alguna celebración pero si nosotros
logramos entender que la vida
que existir es un regalo tiene que ser
una celebración la vida ya venimos de un
proceso de amor de un creador tenemos
que entender que somos seres de amor y
de luz y que tenemos todas las
posibilidades en nuestras manos para que
la vida sea una celebración no
necesariamente en la época que va bien
cuando va bien todos andamos altiro esto
aplica cuando las cosas no van mal es
una perspectiva de las cosas de verdad
se los platico y me animo estar aquí
enfrente porque yo lo viví y esta frase
a mí me saco el hoyo en su momento yo
del hoyo se oye muy es la forma más
obvia de decirlo pero bueno continuando
me di cuenta del tema de las emociones
estos regalos que yo daba estas
calcomanías empieza hacer playeras se
las daba a mis amigos la empresa dedicar
un chorro de tiempo cuando lo que menos
tenía era tiempo y dinero
el caso es que entendí que el lenguaje
universal no es un idioma el lenguaje
universal son las emociones porque las
emociones no importa qué edad tengas de
qué país seas de qué estatus
socioeconómico pertenezca
una emoción que conecta y es empática
logra trascender durante toda la vida es
un canal de comunicación que vamos a
tener es una forma de fluir
hablando de fluir aquí está esta frase
que me gustó mucho de fluir como le dije
yo empecé dando y dando y dando ahorita
estaba hablando en la otra plática de
los libros este pero yo me entendí que
el momento de dar
fue una forma de apostar al presente
para tener un mejor futuro y ya
introspectivo y con todo el aprendizaje
que ha tenido durante estos años entendí
que el dar el fluir se trata de cuando
tienes felicidad hay que agarrarla
disfrutarla pero dársela a alguien más
no hay que quedarnos con las cosas si
vienen cosas tristes o malas hay que
enfrentarlas vivirlas y perdonar o
vivirlas y soltarlas el tratar de cargar
emociones la vida se convierte más
kesabe se trata de vivir ligeros de
navegar la vida de la forma más sencilla
más simple posible acordarnos del origen
llegamos nosotros nuevos llenos de
emociones muy naturales hay que estar
siempre recordando eso con este
movimiento de venimos a pasarla bien que
ya se convirtió en algo grande este y
que en algo que me ha regalado
muchísimas cosas parte de las prácticas
que hago es que salgo a regalar ya crear
emociones aquí les muestro hoy vamos a
salir a la calle arreglarnos playeritas
y pura buena onda
qué onda carnal cómo andas
viernes
una medida como ésta
soy en 10 el viernes bien bien aquí te
regalo esta playerita para que lo estoy
pasando mejor la red
muy bien pues quiero regalarles esta
plantilla si no sale del ánimo nombre
ustedes queda bien
ánimo nos vemos carnal
bueno si se dan cuenta la reacción de
las personas con diego con ellos digo yo
sé que no soy guapo pero tampoco estoy
para las caras que hacen
es porque no estamos acostumbrados a que
nos den y no estamos acostumbrados a dar
entonces este ejercicio personalmente
les digo yo he estado viviendo las cosas
y lo he comprobado por eso me animo a
compartirlo hace una experiencia bien
interesante con estos vídeos la gente
siente la empatía ay qué se hizo
hablando de las emociones se sembró una
emoción seguramente ese muchacho llegó a
su casa y platicó lo que le pasó y en su
entorno familiar generó algo positivo
chiquito que sea pero ya está sumando
entonces este movimiento se de eso se
trata de tratar de crear emociones y una
filosofía en la que nos podamos unir y
poder vivir mejor
y esto de la felicidad tenemos que
lograr entender que la felicidad es una
decisión y no es una edición radical de
que decidas tú no pues yo soy feliz si
voy a hacer todo feliz toda mi vida se
trata de decisiones chicas que tú
decides tomar el paso de la felicidad y
poco a poco se va construyendo tu día o
tu vida en cosas mucho mucho mejores
entonces por eso es muy importante
responsabilizarnos de la felicidad
muchas veces muchos tendemos a decir que
las cosas dependen de otros o que no fue
tu culpa otras cosas entonces el tema de
que la felicidad sea una decisión de lo
que tú decides es tu responsabilidad en
las buenas y en las malas
aquí vemos una decisión un poco loca de
una persona que decidió tatuarse el
logotipo es una decisión hipster yo no
tengo tratado lo este hay 29 personas
que se han tatuado del logotipo a mí se
me hace increíble lo que hablamos de las
emociones cuando la gente conecta pues
esto es una forma de tomar una decisión
de tener un recordatorio yo traigo
gratitud de aquí por medio para buscar
aquí en el suyo que quiero animar a
tatuarse les pasó
y bueno
durante el paso del tiempo y con estos
últimos años con venimos a pasarla bien
me puse a pensar un poco en el tema de
la gravedad nosotros pertenecemos a la
tierra y gravita vamos hacia la tierra
porque el creador aquí nos puso en
nuestro lugar en el que vivimos que
tenemos que cuidar que tenemos que
disfrutar entonces pensando en esa
analogía dije nosotros como individuos
nos podemos convertir en un centro de
gravedad
esa energía que nosotros creemos con
nuestros pensamientos y con nuestras
acciones que es lo más importante hacer
que no se queden ideas puedes hacer que
las cosas en las que tú realmente crees
se acerquen a ti que es desde amistades
desde emociones cosas que te pasen lo
que sucede con el destino etcétera
entonces cuando las cosas gravitan hacia
ti van a pertenecer y se van a quedar
así como nosotros estamos en la tierra y
las cosas que lleguen y no gravitan
hacia ti se van a ir como un astronauta
en la luna que no puede pertenecer y
necesita peso para estar ahí forzado
entonces los invito a tratar de ser un
centro de gravedad yo lo he vivido con
este movimiento de muchas formas
increíbles aquí les pongo un ejemplo de
por mí no venimos a pasarla bien me tocó
conocer acá lo ancho que es un cantante
famoso con una filosofía muy padre
hicimos un juntamos fondos para un plan
de reforestación logramos reforestar el
bosque de la primavera en guadalajara
fueron más de 1.200 árboles juntamos
bastante dinero con un movimiento juntos
él con su marca yo con la mía él gravitó
hacia venimos a pasarla bien él siendo
una persona famosa con toda la
credibilidad de lo pueden ver con la
gorra y con todo con todo puesto nos
hemos convertido en muy muy buenos
amigos entonces ahí está un ejemplo de
cómo gravitó hacia la marca algo por
estarlo repitiendo que como decíamos
venía de un periodo que no era de
felicidad
y pues los invito a que encuentren su
mantra yo agarré venimos a pasarla bien
al chino 18 17 años se le ocurrió donde
sigo siendo fiel me ha servido mucho
ahorita ya hay miles de personas que lo
traen también en nuestras redes sociales
busquen su mantra su mente o su objetivo
la vida en temas claros usted sólo esté
repitiendo es más cerca de llegar es
como cuando vas a ir a algún lugar si tú
tienes el mapa o el destino dónde llegar
va a llegar más fácil que si no sabes a
dónde vas y te es un tema de creencias
entonces pues los invito a sonreír y
recordar es que la vida venimos a
pasarla bien gracias
[Aplausos]